vladimir joger has become one of the
first heroes of the new russian
recognized donetsk people's republic the
dpr
to much of the rest of the world he was
a separatist fighting ukraine for
control of its sovereign territory
for the several thousand mourners here
he was fighting for peace
firstly they are defenders of our land
they are for truth they are for the
fatherland this is like the great
patriotic war
i think this is my duty
this man gave his life for freedom and
independence of our great republic
i had to come he fights for us for all
of us for peace
jogger was the commander of the dpr's
elite sparta battalion his soldiers say
he'd gone to rescue civilians from an
apartment building in volnovaca during
what was supposed to be a humanitarian
ceasefire on saturday but his unit got
trapped in a firefight with what they
called ukrainian nationalists
jogger was shot
one of the people who will report this
story across social media to the russian
public is a well-known and influential
war reporter semyon
those who fight civilians are terrorists
so for me it's not a military operation
but a counter-terrorist operation for me
the militants and neo-nazis who
practically control ukraine now are the
same as isil terrorists
the mourners are chanting we will not
forgive we will not forget
vladimir putin has awarded vladimir
joger posthumously the title hero of
russia it's the country's highest honor
given for service to the russian state
and nation
before the invasion of ukraine more than
14 000 people had died in the fighting
to try and bring this region closer to
russia russian donbass that sign reads
now most men have been drafted to the
military there's more death it's hard to
imagine how this region would be allowed
to return to ukrainian control
bernard smith al-jazeera donetsk